Disney and Nickelodeon have been giving
us quality TV shows for decades and we
can't help but feel a little nostalgic
stay tuned to see which number one star
decided to leave the nickelodeon nest
behind let's get to the ten stars we
wish for still on TV Miley Cyrus in
Hannah Montana we can't talk about old
Disney shows without talking about
Hannah Montana this show was on TV from
2006 until 2011 and it was one of the
most popular Disney Channel shows of all
time Miley Cyrus played Miley Stewart a
girl with a huge secret in her free time
she was a superstar named Hannah Montana
Miley was just a kid when this show
started and she became an instant hit
the show was hilarious and Miley proved
herself to be one talented actress but
acting wasn't really Miley's dream when
she left Hannah Montana
she turned her TV show life into her
real life Miley became a chart-topping
pop star with hits like party in the USA
and wrecking ball and her carefree
attitude has made her the center of
several controversies but to say she
isn't quite the innocent Disney star
that she used to be these days she is
dating Liam Hemsworth she was most
recently in the news for losing her home
in the huge fires in California love her
hate her Miley Cyrus definitely made
Disney Channel amazing and we miss
Hannah Montana miranda cosgrove in
iCarly back in 2007 Nickelodeon started
a brand new show that was made for the
digital age in 2007 YouTube stars were a
pretty new thing and it was everyone's
dream to have their videos and vlogs go
viral well that was exactly what
happened in icarly carly shay was a
regular teenage girl with the web show
she did everything from comedy sketches
to songs and then her show becomes a
huge internet sensation the show was all
about how Carly dealt with her newfound
fame and while trying to be a normal
teenager it was really popular and it
ran all the way to 2012 miranda cosgrove
played Carly and she was amazing she was
not only a great actress but she was
such a talented singer we live for any
chance we get to hear her sing she got
her musical start by singing the theme
song to her TV show which she recorded
with another Nickelodeon star Drake bell
while she was playing Carly she
released a studio album some singles and
a couple EPS since icarly ended she's
done some acting you might recognize her
as the voice of Margo from the
despicable Me movies we would love to
see Miranda back on Nickelodeon to show
us what icarly is up to now you just
have a terrible terrible personality
dylan and Cole Sprouse in The Suite Life
of Zack and Cody this next show was a
Disney Channel hit it was so successful
that after the usual three season run
Disney made a spin-off show The Suite
Life of Zack and Cody was all about two
twin boys who lived at a hotel Zach and
Cody were always up to no good
they were always causing trouble and
playing pranks the cast of characters
was amazing mr. Moseby was the grumpy
bellhop and London was the spoiled
daughter of the hotel owner and let's
not forget about Ashley Tisdale playing
Maddie
the twins babysitter this show was
always good for a laugh when it ended
Disney aired the suite life on deck
basically the boys get a chance to go to
a special school on a cruise ship
so where are dylan and Cole Sprouse
these days after their Disney Channel
days the boys went to NYU to get degrees
and acting Dylan acts occasionally but
he also owns a bar Cole returned to TV
acting he plays duck head on the hit
series river del it's a lot darker show
than the sweet life Drake Bell in Drake
and Josh
in 2004 Nickelodeon decided to take on a
real-life problem that affects kids
everywhere what if all the sudden you
end up with a stepbrother and a
stepsister it can be really hard to have
a new sibling especially if you're both
really different Drake Bell played Drake
the popular kid at school who was also a
musician Josh Peck played Josh a nerdy
responsible team Drake has a little
sister named Megan who makes their lives
miserable but it always had us up in our
feels it was a great show about blended
families and it was so relatable but
then it ended after just four seasons
and we totally miss it where is Drake
Bell now well he's still doing some
acting he's especially done a lot of
voice acting playing roles like
spider-man
he's also directed and starred in
several short films his next film is
called - the adventures of bunny Bravo
he's released a few albums and his last
EP came out in 2017 he also owns his own
indie
your label we're glad he is still acting
and singing but it's just not the same
without his crazy adventures on Hilary
Duff in Lizzie McGuire
before there was Hannah Montana Disney
Channel had another blonde teenage star
Lizzie McGuire was a super popular show
that started back in 2001 Lizzie McGuire
was really just a normal teenage girl
she wasn't the most popular kid at
school but she wasn't a nerd either she
had two best friends Miranda and Gordo
and she had a huge crush on the popular
Ethan craft the show was all about her
life which was so relatable but there
was one twist Lizzie McGuire had an
animated version of herself
this tiny animated Lizzie would pop up
on the screen and say what the real
Lizzie was thinking she was sarcastic
and hilarious we really missed the super
realistic portrayal of middle school
life - Lizzie was played by Hilary Duff
she was a huge teenage star in the early
2000s she was in the rom-com a
cinderella story and the Lizzie McGuire
Movie after she stopped acting on the
show she did several small roles like a
bunch of other Disney stars she also
focused on her musical career she
released five studio albums she
disappeared from the limelight for a
while and started a family she also
started a clothing line it would be so
cool to get a follow up show about
Lizzie being a mom or something just
like Raven did Hilary Duff will always
be Lizzie McGuire to us Selena Gomez in
Wizards of Waverly Place in 2007 Disney
Channel aired the first episode of one
of their most popular shows ever Wizards
of Waverly Place was one of the few
Disney Channel shows to run longer than
three seasons it was all about a normal
family that owned a restaurant but they
were a magical family only one of the
three kids can be a wizard forever they
all get magic training and have to
compete to be the family wizard it was
such a funny show and it always made us
want to be magical the middle child in
the show was Alex she was played by none
other than Selena Gomez selena has acted
some after the show ended but she really
focused on her musical career and she is
a hit pop star she has made it on to the
top 10 billboard lists not once but
seven times as of 2017 she has sold 7
million albums and
twenty-two million singles worldwide she
is just one talented actress we really
wish she was on our TVs every week with
the other wizards but we are glad she is
returning to acting Selena has at least
three movies coming up in the next
couple of years
stay tuned to find out which other pop
star we really wish was still on TV Shia
LaBeouf in even Stephens this next actor
might be one of the most successful
Disney Channel stars ever way back at
the turn of the century Disney Channel
had a show called even Stephens
the Stephens were a normal family from
California but Lewis is the youngest and
he has trouble fitting in his siblings
are basically perfect in his eyes and he
just isn't so he goes to great and
hilarious lengths to stand out the
oldest Stephens kid is a sports legend
who was super popular at school the
middle child is smart and always makes
perfect grades Lewis is goofy and
mischievous he's always up to something
it was because of even Stephens that
Shia LaBeouf got his big break he went
on to star in a ton of movies he was the
star of the Transformers movies he
played Indiana Jones's son in the 2008
adventure movie Indiana Jones and the
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull Shia is one
of the most recognizable faces in
Hollywood lately he has acted in several
indie films and he is such a talented
actor we know he has gone on to bigger
and better things
but sometimes we wonder what Louis
Stevens and his family would be up to
these days to beat me down
just take the plate Amanda Bynes in the
Amanda show we're going way back for
this next star back in the 1990s sketch
comedy shows were all the rage and for
those of us who weren't allowed to stay
up and watch Saturday Night Live and
MADtv we had Nickelodeon first there was
all that which was a kids version of SNL
but in 1999 Nickelodeon gave us the
super popular sketch show starring
Amanda Bynes
she was so popular on all that that she
got her own show and it was hilarious
sometimes she played judge Trudy but her
most popular character was Penelope
Danes
Penelope was a really nerdy stalker who
claimed to be Amanda's number one fan
the Amanda Show was on for three amazing
seasons and then Amanda Bynes became
really popular for a few years she was
in several popular teen romantic
including she's the man and what a girl
wants after acting in eza in 2010
Amanda totally disappeared from the
spotlight it's actually really sad she
became addicted to drugs and started
hanging out with some shady people
she went to fashion school and graduated
in the summer of 2018 although we missed
seeing Amanda on our TVs and in the
movies we're glad she's taking care of
herself
Ricky Ullman in Phil of the future way
before Nickelodeon got into the robot
game with i''m Frankie
Disney had another teen sci-fi show all
about fitting in Phil at the future was
on Disney from 2004 to 2006 the Diffie
family is from the year 21 21 but they
time-travel and get stuck in the year
2004 they have advanced technology that
is super cool Phil as the oldest
difficut he's a freshman in high school
when the show starts and his best friend
turns of love interest is the only one
who knows the truth about the dippy
family they also have a caveman who is
stowed away in the family's time machine
Rick Ullman played Phil he now goes by
his real Israeli name Raviv Ullman in
2008 he was on the show
Rita rocks after 2009 most of his acting
was done on the stage in 2018 he
appeared in three episodes of strangers
after not doing any movies or TV shows
since 2015 he also does a lot of
activist work we wish we could find out
what filled if he from the future is up
to these days ariana grande in
victorious in 2010 nickelodeon aired the
first season of victorious it was all
about Tori Vega and her friends at an
Arts High School in Hollywood all of the
characters were fun and unique including
Cat Valentine
she's sweet and bubbly but she isn't too
smart Kat was such a popular character
that she got a spinoff series called Sam
and cat cat Valentine was played by the
famous ariana grande and it was because
of her bull on these shows that she got
her big break we are so glad she did she
hasn't really acted since Sam and Kat
ended because she is just such a
talented singer she has had three
number-one albums and tons of hit
singles Ariana has a unique smoky voice
and her songs are amazing her latest
single thank you next hit the number one
spot on the hot 100 billboard in
November 2018 she is
also billboards 2018 woman of the year
we love Ariana's music but sometimes we
miss teen Cat Valentine on TV we are so
glad that Nickelodeon discovered one of
our favorite artists which Disney
Channel and Nickelodeon stars do you
wish were still on TV sound off in the
comments those are ten of the Disney
Channel and Nickelodeon stars that we
wish were still on TV be sure to check
out our community page and hit that
subscribe button for more awesome
content see you later
[Music]